[Música]
Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de Franz 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
en Belice uno de los países más pequeños
de Centroamérica desde el año 1958 viven
los menonitas una minoría de cristianos
Ultra ortodoxos de ascendencia europea a
pesar de representar apenas el 4% de la
población de Belice son quienes
controlan y surten al país y Alimentos
indispensables como el pollo la leche y
el maíz los menonitas son un mundo
aparte que opera con Independencia
religiosa fiscal y educativa y se han
vuelto indispensables para la industria
agrícola belicemia provocando recelo de
parte de otras comunidades y del
gobierno central de Belmopán hoy nos
acompañan Andrés Suárez y Aurora bayú
autores de este reporteros comienzo con
Andrés Hola Andrés en el caso particular
de Belice los menonitas lograron un
acuerdo con el gobierno desde hace 60
años para que les dieran grandes
extensiones de tierra a cambio no sólo
de su nacionalidad sino de que las
trabajarán en el sector agrícola Cómo se
mantiene en la actualidad este pacto
Hola herminia el pacto se mantiene
intacto tanto los menonitas necesitan de
Belice como Belice necesita de los
menonitas por ser ese motor agricultor
del país e históricamente la relación ha
sido de mucho respeto sin embargo es una
relación muy intensa dado ese privilegio
de autonomía del que gozan los menonitas
la relación si tuvo un punto de fractura
muy visible durante la pandemia de covid
19 cuando Belice como muchos otros
países del Mundo impuso obligatoriedad
como del uso del tapabocas de no asistir
a las escuelas del cierre de lugares
públicos confinamiento cuarentenas
dentro de la lógica de los menonitas
aquello no era posible y ellos
desacataron todas estas instrucciones
siguieron asistiendo a misa los domingos
y llevando a sus hijos al colegio
algunos pastores fueron arrestados
muchos de los padres de los niños
recibieron entonces multas restricciones
por desacatar al gobierno y se pudo ver
por primera vez como había un choque de
fuerzas Pues los menonitas se conciben
autónomos ellos se dicen a políticos
pero si a futuro esa libertad de
autonomía se ve amenazada pues muy
Seguramente se van a inmiscuir en
política Aunque quién sabe cómo les vaya
porque son una minoría en este país
centroamericano gracias Andrés veamos la
historia
[Música]
por las calles de spanish una comunidad
alejada de la costa Caribe de Belice se
ve pasear diariamente a estos
agricultores
uniformados a la moda de Tom Sawyer a
estos descendientes de antiguos
neerlandeses y alemanes se les conoce
como menonitas
distintos a ellos los menonitas
moderadamente modernos del pueblo son
los poderosos líderes de la industria
agroalimentaria en este país
centroamericano
desde su llegada en 1958 los menonitas
apostaron por producir la carne
predilecta de los belicemos asombroso
dirige la empresa de pollos más
importante de todo Belice la Quality
products
por el precio de la proteína de un pollo
no hay otro producto que le pueda
competir
es un excelente fuente de proteínas para
su precio
por ejemplo el pescado Está a 15 dólares
la libra
mientras el pollo está a 2.20 lo mismo
pasa con la res y el cerdo en esta
planta de producción donde trabajan en
su mayoría hijos de refugiados
guatemaltecos se embalan 30.000 pollos a
diario que pasan a almacenarse en un
cuarto frío este es el frío de Canadá
más frío que los inviernos canadienses
aquí lo que tenemos es el lugar donde
almacenamos el pollo de aquí lo enviamos
a todo el país lo distribuimos a cada
Distrito o sucursal después de aquí
va al mercado aquí lo congelamos
mientras tanto
lo amamos amamos nuestro pollo queremos
venderlo a todo el mundo
[Música]
lo particular de esta industria es que
no es de un solo dueño le pertenece a
los más de 100 socios de la comunidad de
spanish por lo que cada familia
accionista cuenta con su propio establo
para engordar los pollos los importan
recién nacidos desde Estados Unidos
quien simula la figura del alcalde
también usufructua de la industria
Avícola del pueblo
los menonitas de spanish luckout
cultivan o producen el 50% de todo el
pollo de Belice
el otro 50% lo producen las otras
comunidades menonitas así que todo el
pollo de Belice lo producen los
menonitas en el caso de spanish hay
muchas granjas pequeñas como la mía
donde la gente tiene gallineros con un
cupo de hasta 5000 pollos
como lo dice led y siendo apenas el 4%
de la población de Belice los menonitas
dominan el monopolio Avícola de todo el
país un fruto del pacto suscrito con el
gobierno de la otrora Honduras británica
que les vendieran grandes extensiones de
selva tropical a tres dólares el acre a
cambio de transformarlas en productivos
latifundios
Wow los menonitas se mudaron aquí en
cuando se mudaron aquí esto era una
selva espesa y densa a diferencia de lo
que se ve Ahora
te necesito mucho trabajo duro mucha
cooperación mucha gente sudó murió mucha
sangre y sacrificio para el desarrollo
de este lugar
la actual riqueza de spanish Es evidente
a la vista con un condado de 32.000
hectáreas para 3.000 personas
las familias viven en casas sin rejas
calcadas de la arquitectura americana
con tejados a dos aguas para la nieve
que nunca cae en Centroamérica y el
Caribe
un pueblo sin bares ni casinos donde
acudir a la iglesia los domingos es un
Rito sagrado de la sociedad que
mantienen en cualquier lugar del mundo
donde deciden vivir
[Música]
los menonitas se llaman así por el líder
religioso menon simons un antiguo
sacerdote neerlandés que rompió con la
iglesia católica del siglo XVI para
convertirse en pastor
perseguidos por discordias religiosas
como creer En el bautismo de los adultos
los menonitas escaparon a Rusia y de
allí emigraron a Canadá Estados Unidos
México Belice Bolivia y Paraguay
sí disfrutamos de una muy buena libertad
religiosa aquí en Belice estamos
realmente agradecidos por ello Es una de
las cosas estipuladas desde cuando los
menonitas llegaron a Belice
Y es que los menonitas rezarán a Dios
por el gobierno
tanto dentro como fuera de la iglesia se
observa que los menonitas establecen una
segregación de género en el código de
vestimenta de las mujeres no se
consiente el uso de pantalones y se
exige un pañuelo en la cabeza como
símbolo de sometimiento a Cristo y al
liderazgo de los hombres
[Música]
sin embargo no todas las mujeres
menonitas de spanish luckout concuerdan
con la regla Berta raimer es una
excepción no sólo por vestirse a su
manera sino también por ser la primera
mujer menonita adoptada en Belice
los padres de los primeros menonitas que
se establecieron en Belice en 1958 al no
poder concebir hijos biológicos le
preguntaron a la iglesia si les dejaban
adoptar les dijeron que no que no está
bien
que no queremos que otra cultura se
mezcle con la nuestra
ligeramente anárquicos sus padres La
adoptaron en Honduras con tres meses de
nacida así Berta se convirtió en la
primera menonita en Belice sin ojos
azules ni pelo rubio
siempre se burlaron de nosotros ya que
nos llamaban con apodos por nuestro
color de piel
que éramos negras y ni siquiera éramos
negras éramos morenas como latinas
aunque con el mismo apellido pero de
diferente parentesco otros raimer en
spanish son menos liberales y más
conservadores
Ernest rainer es otro menonita que
encontró un vacío en la agricultura
beliceña
this Este es un campo de maíz aquí en
Belice utilizamos el maíz para la
mayoría de los alimentos de animales que
fabricamos
es muy importante para nosotros
alrededor del 60 o 65% de los alimentos
que fabricamos son a base de maíz
quieren mirar ese poquito
la producción de maíz frijol y sorgo
entre otros cereales también es manejada
por los menonitas en Belice
A qué estamos en la fábrica de piensos
Gamers en spanish una empresa de
nutrición animal
es el dueño de más del 70% de esta
empresa de alimentos para todo tipo de
animales
avaluada en más de 10 millones de
dólares comenzó su producción
precariamente a finales de los años 50
Esta es la casa donde empezamos la
fábrica de piensos Gamers en julio de
el tío comenzó a mezclar el alimento ahí
lo comenzó a moler tenía un pequeño
molino de Martillo molé el maíz los
parcía en el suelo le agregaba la harina
de soya y todos los ingredientes los
mezclaba con la pala y esperaba que
estuviera sólido
Ahí es donde empezamos
aparte de vender en todo Belice sus
alimentos para animales Ernest raymer
nutre a las 35 vacas que tiene en su
casa con sus productos
Este es el alimento para las vacas que
hacemos en la fábrica de piensos aquí se
ve tiene alrededor de 60% de maíz y el
resto son los otros aditivos
las moliendas la harina de soya que es
un polvo oscuro más fino y que se mezcla
especialmente para las vacas lecheras
bien alimentadas con piensos ricos en
proteína las vacas de los menonitas
también son protagonistas en Belice
el 85% de todos los productos lácteos
que se consumen en el país proviene del
esfuerzo de familias como la de Ernest
rainer Entonces quieres probarlo así
mientras las mujeres administran los
hogares Y los hombres las empresas los
niños menonita van a la escuela para
estudiar la Biblia en nueve niveles de
aprendizaje
Esto es lo más importante para nosotros
y por eso también lo hacemos por la
mañana dicen que si los niños lo
aprenden por la mañana también les ayuda
a recordar lo mejor a lo largo de la
vida el profesor randolph también Les
enseña matemáticas y lenguaje pero no
mucho más
un sistema educativo incompatible con
los requisitos de las universidades del
mundo
Esa es la cuestión que la mayoría no va
a la universidad hay algunos que sí pero
la mayoría solo hace el bachillerato y
ya está
Supongo que nuestra gente no ve el
sentido de ir a la universidad
para qué ir a la universidad si su
destino ya está escrito heredar la
misión agrícola que les abrió a sus
abuelos las puertas de un país
muy pronto sobre ellos recaerá la
responsabilidad que lograron sus
familias de mantener la autosuficiencia
alimentaria que actualmente contribuye
al 11% del producto interno bruto de
Belice
[Aplausos]
[Música]
estamos de vuelta con Aurora wayú
también coautora de este reporteros Hola
Aurora después de ver el reportaje
notamos que los menonitas tienen valores
conservadores marcados Qué otros
detalles pudieron observar de esta
comunidad en específico la de spanish
Pues algo que sí pudimos observar en
spanish lucaut creo que es una
asignación de roles muy clara entre un
hombre y una mujer muy clásica también
de la mujer va a ser la que se encarga
de los niños de las tareas del hogar en
cambio el hombre es quizás el que tiene
la fuerza de decisión por ejemplo no sé
si se pudieron dar cuenta pero en el
reporte casi no aparecen mujeres no es
porque no intentamos es porque sentíamos
que sin el acuerdo de su marido muchas
no se atrevían a hablar con nosotros
hasta que conocimos a una mujer joven
menonita que ya sí nos dio una
entrevista espectacular porque pues
hablaba desde su perspectiva como mujer
menonita como ella lo estaba viviendo
hasta hubo un momento divertido porque
nos explicaba muy claramente que como
mujer vestir un pantalón era una falta
de humildad ante el hombre y pues Y
obviamente tenía pantalones ese día pero
bueno algo que fue muy frustrante para
nosotros pero también que que creo que
ilustra un poco todo eso es que luego no
supimos bien Qué pasó pero sí nos pidió
Borrar todo ese material algunos días
después
Gracias Aurora hasta aquí reporteros de
la semana recuerde que para sintonizar
esta y las ediciones anteriores puede
visitar nuestro sitio web France 24.com
hasta la próxima
[Música]